where's the girl with the director
tattoo when they do to us I tell you
what she's gonna do to us she's gonna
cut off my dick and feed it to me a very
cut off a bull dick and I'm hungry yeah
as soon as she dies is your little dick
up your decent-sized dick thank you
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo is going
to kill us hey guys oh wow announce
yourself next time sorry some friend of
yours brought you a steak lunch I
thought it was snake lunch at first but
then she clarified it's a snake lunch
and I'm not jealous PS huh thank you it
looks like uh dragon tats is coming
around thank you she probably forgot we
owe her money
yeah stoner all right no oh come on
enjoy this meal on me sincerely you know
who guys know who probably is it's
probably the Dragon Tattoo girl ah boy I
feel like a silly goof on we were all
worried about no no no good 20 toe
you